on this episode I answer how to bookmark
it we talked about elementary school
students and Wuzzles
[Music]
you asked for
to them this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 113 of
the askgaryvee show super pumped up nice
day but you know wasn't can France so
con can so didn't get to do as many
shows as I wanted to at the end of last
week been missing a lot of you the best
of askgaryvee show I just watched the
first couple minutes of the Edit so I'm
super excited about that we'll be
releasing that shortly I'm around this
week so we'll have a good amount of
shows I'm even trying to sneak one in
tomorrow
I know Wednesday we're firm Thursday
were firm Friday reform know so today
Wednesday Thursday so three definite
this week I'm just going to try sneak in
a fourth one what am i doing Friday its
fourth of July weekend right very good
point and I'm going to a wedding so I'll
be disappearing um cool uh and yeah
India let's get into the show by the way
real quick real quick um I really like
that little message your dad sent you
about me ripping your ear mite Big Ups
cancer ops sorry about that time yeah
how's your ear it's totally fine totally
yeah okay I'm ready
I'm really I'm super ready for this show
guys I'm really fired up I'm really
pumped I love this show I love all of
you
Ronnie asks if you had the opportunity
to speak in front of an auditorium full
of elementary schoolers what would be
your topic of choice and why my topic of
choice so first of all I was in a room
full of elementary school students like
I was once ever in my career which was
in Houston in a tremendous conference
that I went to where was the best
students from elementary school of all
of Houston and I cursed up a storm and I
talked about like all sorts of crap I
remember I tried to connect with them so
is using like like random hip-hop
artists that were popping at the time
and the teachers were literally
flabbergasted and completely pissed off
and the kids were completely
and like like these are like the
greatest students of like seventh and
eighth grade and all of Houston and like
a third of the class quit school in
seventh grade when I was done with the
talk because what I really talked to
them about was real life which is look
you're a great student you're going down
a certain path right now
bad news education in America is
screwing you over you're going to pop
out and you're gonna realize holy crap
I don't want to do this or this and that
and then I talked about the virtues of
good schooling which is the the
randomness of having a college roommate
that's a billionaire and some of the
other random stuff but you know it was a
tremendous talk my chart my choice of
topic today if I was to today would be
you know I would tell them to to really
recognize how to build self-esteem and
self-awareness
I would pound that and I would say look
you're looking at me and I'm an old dude
up here and I'm cliche just like all
your other teachers and parents but um
you need to find the things that you're
good at and really find the friends that
you're looking for and you know you hear
it a million times that you're not going
to look back and care about the dumb
[ __ ] that you care about now but you
don't believe me but that's not gonna
stop me from trying to pound it down
your little throat oh these are all the
Instagram question you got a lot of
questions from there right so we can do
a couple episodes worth cool I was fun
follow me on Instagram this whole notion
of like where's the time I think that
people like to claim that they work hard
and smart but they're not putting in the
work your hustle your work ethic your
drive is not predicated on your zip code
right hook that's a hashtag you rock oh
that's right I've got about that Oh my
question is about to burning ashes and
Percy you know it's on Jimmy Fallon once
right here the one only wine guru Gary
Vaynerchuk whose daily webcast the
Thunder show on winelibrary.com attracts
over 90,000 viewers a day very
impressive buddy appreciate and you do
what your a wine guru what makes you a
wine guru can you explain it a little
bit self-proclaimed you know just the
title
I'm in a very silly mood today it's a
Monday yeah I love Monday so it's early
Monday morning and I've been wanting to
make a Monday morning video for a long
time but finally dirac we're doing it so
real quick this is just a rant very
simple and something that I want you to
pass on or watch every Monday morning
because the level of complaining is
unacceptable look yeah Lots
editing this is not going to we're
taping this so early and it's going to
come out so late
pixel art asks is it possible to have
two burning passions and pursue them at
the same time without half-assing them
or is it ideal to pick one at a time
that's a really good question um you
know I think that I think there's people
that have two burning passions at the
same time I really do and I wonder if
you can wuzzle them and and make them
both work at the same time that was a
1980s rare television cartoon Saturday
morning reference wuzzle do you know
what was our India search it right now
let's watch India's faces she's gonna
love these watches this is India in real
time this is India in real time yet
wazzle w-well yes see it uh-huh
go to images because this is Wikipedia
go to images I want you to like really
wrap your head around how cool these
things are cool right there are two
animals in one so she was like a hippo
and a butterfly you see what's going on
here two animals in one bang that's what
I was looking for uh-huh uh-huh so maybe
you can wazzle them right and find a way
to make your two passions for example
you know I could have very easily made
Wine Library TV and the jet what's going
on here but wuzzle them like take your
two passions and smash them into one
like for example I could have done all
my wine episodes at football games that
would been a further you know I the Jets
bucket but you know there's ways to
unique I think you know I once said and
a lot of you liked this photo on
Instagram uh you know if you order this
quote if you want to be an anomaly you
have to act like one
I wonder based on this question if you
could be the first person that combines
two things that nobody's ever combined
before which are you know weird and when
for example again I loved wrestling what
if I did Wine Library TV only a
tailgates or football environments and
wrestling matches like independence
circuits like weird stuff where 150
people in the audience at a gym and not
in cheeks still there you know like
stuff like that so I'm a big fan of
trying to find a way to wuzzle them and
and that's what I would do now obviously
a lot of people are going to tell you
pick one focus I may say that at times
today I felt like was lling them
tomorrow if I answer this question I
might say pick one both can work I think
at the end of the day and we talk a lot
about this it's about self-awareness and
you know it's funny I'm reading every
goddamn comment in facebook specifically
right now I'm on a Facebook comment kind
of spree so I apologize to all the
youtubers but that's just what's
happening and and it's interesting I you
know I'm feeling more and more pressure
on my shoulders more than ever before
because the show is picking up so much
momentum and I'm watching so many people
comment about them implementing and
seeing results and it makes me hungry
ambitious greedy to try to impact more
people with what is really working which
is if you really know yourself really
India this question comes down to a very
simple place which is it's one of two
choices it's truly one of two choices
it's really just two levers it's
happiness and financial um and
street-cred
upside it's just trying to pull the lip
and listen I do this I think a lot of
you may be confused I leave enormous
amounts of money on the table for
happiness I just do I do it all the time
the largest speaking gig of my career a
number that makes me vomit on the table
out of happiness I passed on because
it's week four in the Jets are playing
in London and I want to go watch Jets
play the Dolphins in London and I'm by
the way this is a significant number
this is a hefty six-figure deal this is
this is more money than I made a three
year period in my mid-20s to go in MC
and speak at an event for
a day and a half still could have
watched the Jets like I do all the time
and I'm choosing happiness over cash and
we all have to do that all the time and
our lives evolve I'm in a better
financial place than I was seven years
ago maybe then I would have chose cash I
don't know but but even in my early days
for example when I lost an eighth of
faith Jesus a third of my entire wealth
in my 20s to have fun in Vegas and lose
it all gambling was because I chose
happiness kind of sadness over over over
wealth and so the answer to this
question is predicated very simply do I
believe there's I'm gonna really I'm
really breaking this down India um if
you wuzzle it you may pop and be an
anomaly and have disproportionate
success because your first guy to ever
bring spaghetti and music together in
this way most likely you won't and your
financial upside is probably predicated
on picking one and going all-in
most likely however you just might have
more happiness mixing the two and have
the homerun Grand Slam potential of
breaking out which is why I always do
those things I'm always picking my
happiness versus the street an obvious
course because I've got a little bit of
magic and sometimes my weird stuff
actually works as well and the boo boo
prize is that I'm happier and boy
happiness is addicting you know what I'm
going to actually throw a right hook
here right now in donation serious right
book
I love Wuzzles please go to ebay and buy
me some stuffed animal was also I can
put him right here on the show it's a
very inexpensive way for you to get a
shout out
that's all in black and white I'm gonna
start doing more of that I love eBay and
and like garage sale culture and I'm
gonna I'm gonna start getting the fans
to buy me random [ __ ] I mean the show's
free you might as well pay some sort of
big table yeah I just want tables full
of random crap collectibles things that
I want then I'm gonna flip them back on
eBay and make a profit on your ass what
a funk asks yo Gary Vee can you rate my
Instagram on a one to ten scale and tell
me how to improve yeah let's do it live
I love nd a great job great question so
here we are
what if Uncas who I've seen plenty of
times in my stream so here's his
clothing thing I don't can you can you
get here I'm gonna rate it here see
what's going on and a lot of engagement
right we'll see ya the other way just
kidding um the pictures of tremendous
let's play this video I love it I love
the get on this um so 1,500 followers 10
15 20 engagements the engagements are a
hair low um I mean I really like the
photos I just honestly I don't think
your growth hacking enough I need you I
think you need a lot more of a fanbase
in my homies shoppers and yeah I mean
the cup the content is is fine I mean I
think I'd rate it a six or seven I think
it's it's - I think at this point you're
too small and you need to try a lot of
different things quote cards zoomed in
versions of the clothes like I think you
could mix it up a little bit how often
is he posting idiot while I'm getting
the answer trying to give me a general
yeah I would go with three times a day
to find your cadence and find your thing
I'd rather lose 10 to 20% of my audience
to see if I can find the upside whoo
that was a really strong good piece of
advice for a lot of people on Instagram
let me say it again good
that was me rewinding I'd rather lose 10
to 20% of my audience by posting 3 times
a day if I was filling up their feed and
make sure you're being strategic about
those posts and doing very different
things to maybe find pay dirt as a
thematic creatively for your upside I'd
also start reaching out at scale your
products you're selling hats and shirts
and stuff like that you need to reach
out all day long all day long in the
comments go to Instagram go to people
that have 5,000 and 50,000 followers
that are you know got your vibe as a
user and leave a comment in their latest
picture saying I want to give you some
swag you know can we do something you've
got to get more distribution and
awareness and I would do that by giving
away product for them to give you
shoutouts on their screen and siphon
siphon their audience cool what's that I
see Matt don't worry Syd the interns
getting a little bit concerned just what
I saw him said but you have to
understand he works for me not the other
way around but I appreciate and more
portly should always know that I'm
seeing everything I see him but I
appreciate it whenever you want to do
let's go fast because Matt's circling
around Jared asks if you have a business
that is growing fast is it more
important to perfect the system and
process or focus on adding more people
to the team Jared is a good question I'm
a big fan of both I don't understand why
not both I do both as building
vaynermedia I was perfecting the system
while hiring people and training them up
and building out the team this is not an
either-or my man and this is where I
think people struggle to really be
victorious I think you need to be able
to do both at the same time that's what
separates the women from the girls right
the ability to be able to do both things
at the same time and by the way that's
where Hustle comes in because you know
what to do both
you've got to kind of integrate the team
nine-to-five while kind of spending five
to like 2:00 in the morning to perfect
the system this is where Hustle matters
this is where extra hours in the day
actually matter because he can't get to
both actually like physically you can't
get to both and so in a nine hour
workday so if you've got a business
that's growing fast first question is
are you actually deploying 18 hours a
day because remember too many of you
have missed or are gonna miss your
moment in time when it's happening when
it's happening
if you don't triple pedal down that's
pedal on the metal like foot on the
pedal like if you don't go all the hell
in all of it if you don't do that at
that moment you will regret you would
missed your moment in time and that is
why I'm burning the candle from both
sides right now because everything is
hitting a proper crescendo as I'm going
into my 40th birthday in November
vaynermedia vayner/rse my fund cruising
rate you know just cruising and the
askgaryvee show cruising you know just a
family life and health I mean cruising
and so I got a push harder because you
know what at 42 it might just be that
break in that moment I'm where things
aren't cruising as much and so you've
got extract you've got to extract all
the value when you're hitting that point
you've got to live it you know you just
have the limit as a matter fact for all
of you that on your senior year of high
school that are watching your show
squeeze the crap out of that because
it's the best and college like you've
got to squeeze everything all the time
especially this question really hits a
nerve because I want people to
understand the answer is both Gary Vee
what's up Lewis house here from the
school of greatness podcast big fan of
the askgaryvee show
keep it up love what you're doing I've
got a two-part question for you
and it's geared around selling books
I've got a big book launch coming out in
October and the fall it's called the
school of greatness very excited about
it
and I've got two-part question for you
one with Instagram ads looking like
they're gonna be opening up here soon
somebody's paying attention you could
always spend money in one place on ads
Facebook or Instagram where would you be
putting your money on a book launch
coming out this fall that's part one in
part two if you were looking to get
10,000 pre-orders through bulk orders
where would you be focusing your energy
and efforts to get 10,000 pre-orders
piece of cake because I've done it so
much hope you like it thanks I love that
Louis uh I would I'm hedging here
because I just don't know exactly what
Instagram is gonna do if I knew that
Instagram is gonna fully open up the
funnel the firehose and ads are just
rolling in and we're seeing five seven
ads a day on our feed then I would say
Instagram
I really would cuz I do believe the
attention is sitting in Instagram the
problem is my intuition without any
knowledge is there going to be a little
tighter on the spigot and and it's gonna
be a little tougher to actually break
through and so I would spend 50 cents on
a dollar in Facebook and Instagram the
problem is your books coming out in
October the ad proper I'm supposed to
come out in October my belief is it
comes out later so I think I want you
mentally in facebook facebook is going
to dominate number two choose a piece of
cake because I've done it multiple times
and I'll do it again in March or
February for my askgaryvee book the
place to go is to your homies the place
to go is to your homies what I mean by
that is reverse engineer everything
you've done for people for the last 18
months and send them one by one
not in bulk biggest mistake people make
is send a bulk email and say this is the
one time I want to send a bulk email you
know I I just need all of you to buy my
book I get that all the time that is a
piece of crap execution it will not work
I don't feel like it's personal I never
buy but Luis when you email me and you
write a whole thing like hey remember
when we first met in Ohio and I drove
you around or st. Louis and I drove you
around and this and that and you know
thanks for being on my podcast and hey
remember a couple months ago you I asked
this question on the show so here's my
thing and hey it was great to see that
like real stuff like real stuff like the
party in LA that I have like real
stuff real stuff that happened between
you and I not a bulk ctrl-c ctrl-v
this is you and me you spent five
minutes writing this email it would
really mean a lot to me I'm gonna be
guilted into buying 100 bucks and that's
it
and you've got a lot of people like that
and some people are even more homey with
you know by a thousand or though by 40
or by ninety and literally when when Jab
Jab right hook came out in that August
that came out in February in that August
or not came it wanted to come out and
genuine there's some when in general
anyway in that August maybe December
anyway in that August I emailed
thousands of people one by one wrote
them one by one emails it took forever
um and I got a lot of sales and well
into the tens of thousands and so that
would that's exactly what I would do I'd
reverse-engineer CRM your whole social
graph the twenty five to seven thousand
people that most matter and one by one
by one remind them the nice things
you've done I know how you roll you
build up leverage one by one by one one
by one by one one by one by one
tedious long an effort that converts an
actual sales and follow-up I went in
right in a be like look you need to say
no in this email or at the time Nate
who's a CEO of the book or Nate is gonna
email you and ask you every week on the
week and I'm cool [ __ ] if you go with no
because I get it cool but you need to
say it because I will bother you until
you tell me and so put them in a corner
suffocate them don't let them be able to
like just delete it and not answer pound
them let them basically understand that
you will not have a relationship going
forward if you don't at least answer and
that no is equally as awesome as a
thousand and that's what I did I really
made everybody feel very comfortable and
saying no because I get it as I did with
them being a thousand it's funny after I
did Jab Jab right hook even though I did
it for crush and thank you economy after
I did for judging a right hook it's
funny I've been giving this advice to a
lot of people and as you guys know we've
been buying a lot of hundreds and to
hundreds and putting them out for Vayner
so that's the scoop my man that's what I
would do
guys thank you for watching the show I
really appreciate it my question of the
day lewis has got me fired up for my
book how many copies of the askgaryvee
book are you going to buy
when it comes out in February or March
very simple question not super
complicated please leave your answer and
lurkers I'm talking workers here's what
a lurker is we talked a lot about on
Wine Library TV I don't bring it up as
much on askgaryvee but i've been looking
at the data there is a boatload a
boatload of you who've watched this show
who've not commented I need you to come
out and at least say hey please you keep
asking questions this was a really good
episode a lot of stuff went on this
episode yelled at Sydney and her I'll
keep answering them
[Music]